across the southern appalachian
mountains from georgia up through north
carolina hundreds of unusual stone
structures have been discovered some
date back hundreds of years some date
back thousands archaeologists aren't
sure who created these monuments but the
cherokee people claim they know exactly
who built them the cherokees say the
structures were built by the moon-eyed
people a race of fair-skinned
light-haired bearded humans their large
blue eyes were so sensitive to sun that
they lived in caves and came out only at
night which is why they're called
moonaid but the story gets even stranger
[Music]
the cherokees say that the muni people
lived in the same area as the cherokee
nation but they were not native american
so if that's true who were they and how
did they get there now christopher
columbus is commonly connected to the
discovery of the new world but there's
plenty of debate on who was really first
norse explorer leith erickson is thought
to have discovered and settled an area
of newfoundland canada around a thousand
a.d and the remains of a norse
settlement were found in newfoundland
not too long ago and the artifacts were
carbon dated to prove that someone was
there at precisely this time there's
also the legend of saint brendan an
irish monk who left ireland in the 6th
century in search of new lands and after
seven years st brendan returned to
ireland and claimed he discovered a land
covered in lush vegetation people
believe he was describing the east coast
of canada but whether norse or irish
none of these ancient settlements were
permanent every legend ends with the
explorers encountering dangerous natives
who drive them off the land and back to
the sea
but what if permanent settlements were
established hundreds of years before
columbus well that brings us to the
legend of explorer prince maddock of
wales now prince matic was the
illegitimate son of welsh king owen
gwenett who ruled wales in the 12th
century when the king died in 1169 his
sons fought for the throne and civil war
broke out and matic didn't want to be a
part of it so he took a few ships and
sailed west he landed in present-day
mobile bay alabama and he was so excited
by what he saw he returned to wales for
more ships and colonists he then sent
back out toward alabama in 1171 he's
never heard from again but prince
matic's story doesn't end there 500
years later in 1666 a welsh minister
named morgan jones set out into the
american wilderness to preach the good
word to the locals the locals were not
receptive jones and his group were
captured and imprisoned by a people
called the dog in present-day south
carolina about to be executed jones
pleaded for his life then the dog chief
approached he was a small light-skinned
man dressed in typical native american
attire jones dropped to his knees and
said have i escaped so many dangers that
must i now be murdered like a dog
the dog chief stared at him with ice
blue eyes and said you shall not die
today and then set him free
now jones couldn't believe his ears the
chief of the dog tribe was speaking
welsh
morgan jones story was not unique there
was another sailor named stedman who was
shipwrecked somewhere between alabama
and florida in the 1660s and he
published an account of encountering a
light-skinned native tribe that spoke
welsh and these stories circulated
throughout the americas for years in the
19th century governor robert dinwiddie
of virginia financed a large and
expensive expedition to find the welsh
indians when lewis and clark set off to
map the louisiana purchase they were
specifically ordered by thomas jefferson
to keep an eye out for welsh tribes who
are known to be pale-skinned
short-statured people with blonde hair
blue eyes and warm beards were the
moonine people direct descendants of
maddox colonists were they the tribes
who built the stone structures all along
the appalachian mountains the remains of
a lot of these structures still exist
and more are being discovered all the
time ford mountain stone wall in georgia
is over a thousand feet long and varies
in height from three to ten feet and
there are structures like this all
around the area there's a lot of debate
on who built the ruins and what their
purpose was some archaeologists say they
were used for social events seasonal
meetings religious ceremonies and
observing astronomy but supporters of
the matic legend disagree
they point out that the teardrop shaped
foundations are similar to ruins found
throughout great britain specifically
similar to doll widow and castle in
north wales but the ruins in wales
aren't religious structures they're
military fortifications this matches the
cherokee legend almost a thousand years
ago the moon eyed people were at war
with cherokee and other local nations so
the moonaid people built forts and walls
to protect themselves using technology
that was unknown to the local tribes
there's even historical evidence of this
in a letter written in 1810 from john
cevier who is the first governor of
tennessee he says that in 1782 he was
told by an indian chief that the walls
were not built by american indians they
were built by white people called the
welsh who lived in the area hundreds of
years ago in 1799 that same governor
servier wrote a report where he
mentioned the discovery of six skeletons
on the ohio river they were wearing
armor bearing the welsh coat of arms
apparently the welsh were driven out of
the land by the cherokee and travel to
the ohio valley or down the mississippi
there's actually evidence of a huge
battle that took place in this area
sometime around 1450. that's almost 50
years before columbus by the way now
local tribes say this was a great battle
between the red indians and the white
indians according to the legend the
white indians lost the war and some of
them began integrating and intermarrying
with a tribe called the mandans the
mandan tribe was said to be very
different than other tribes in
appearance they were fair-skinned with
light hair and light eyes they built
their settlements laid out on a grid
like european cities the mandans didn't
use canoes like most tribes did they
built round bull boats which were
identical to the coracle boats used by
the welsh and the irish the mandan
language to european ears sounded like
welsh and there are a lot of words in
the mandan language that are very close
to medieval welsh are these the moonai
people descendants from a welsh
expedition that arrived in america in
the 1170s according to the cherokee
legend no they can't be you why not well
the cherokee and most other native
people arrived in america at the time of
the last ice age over 10 000 years ago
and possibly many years before that but
the cherokees say that when they came to
america many thousands of years ago the
moon eyed people were already there
[Music]
the cherokee do not consider the moonaid
people white indians they say the
moonaid people were a separate race and
there was no evidence of their
appearance until until until 2015 when
the cherokee county historical museum
put on a display of a very unusual
artifact a statue of two humanoid
creatures about three feet tall and
carved from a single block of soapstone
hundreds or thousands of years ago was
discovered in the blue ridge mountains
of north carolina
what hello
that's an alien yeah a few others have
proposed that theory but for the sake of
this video let's assume that the
moon-eyed people are not from outer
space obviously an alien okay would you
let me get back to this you got it
small in stature with light skin light
hair and large round eyes the moon eyed
people were said to have lived in
appalachia until they lost a long and
bloody war with the cherokee the muni
people were finally defeated when the
cherokee attacked them during a full
moon their blue eyes were so sensitive
to light that they only came out at
night even the full moon was too bright
for them and the cherokee took advantage
of this after the moon eyed were
expelled from cherokee land they went
west and disappeared but they left a
serious imprint on the land they
inhabited the pre-columbian city of
cahokia is said to have been built by
the moonaid people cloaca
cahokia what i say
at its height cahokia's population
exceeded 40 000 people and covered about
six square miles now for comparison at
this time in history london one of the
world's largest cities had a population
only of about 15 000 people covering
about three square miles so half the
size of cahokia in fact it would take
almost a thousand years for a city in
north america to reach 40 000 people
philadelphia did it about the turn of
the 18th century and no city in north
america would reach six square miles
until the 20th century so cahokia was a
metropolis what happened to it nobody
knows but you can visit the ruins of the
city at cahokia mound state park in
illinois the site is over 2 000 acres
and contains 80 man-made mounds of
varying sizes and it's the largest and
most complex archaeological site north
of the aztecs so if the moon-eyed people
are a local legend to the cherokee then
we shouldn't expect to see stories of
white indians or light-skinned
white-haired people anywhere else in the
americas right wait wait have they found
moon-eyed people in other places they
sure have
albinism is a genetic condition that
occurs in all species of animals and
plants and if the tyr gene is altered or
damaged melanin can't be produced and
the animal becomes an albino this
results in white hair feathers skin and
in humans albinism occurs in one out of
every 20 000 births or so but the kuna
tribe of panama has the highest rate of
albinism of any community in the world
one out of every 145 kuna born are
albinos that's over 130 times the
typical rate now in kuna mythology
albinos were given a special
significance their light eyes and skin
color makes them very sensitive to light
people right so they were given the duty
of defending the moon against those who
would try to destroy it in fact they
became known as children of the moon
albino children are born at very high
rates in other native american tribes
the hopi zuni gemez san juan and laguna
tribes all see albinism occurring at
over a hundred times the rate of the
rest of the world are these native
american albinos the descendants of the
moon eyed people which is why their
traits keep showing up in native
populations well we don't know cherokee
said the moon eyed people were driven
west this is interesting the piu people
were a tribe who lived in utah and parts
of california and they talk about city
ka and sitika were a tribe of red-haired
giants with white skin who lived in
caves they feared the sun and they only
came out at night now pew were at war
with the red-haired giants for many
years and eventually they were able to
trap the white-skinned giants in their
caves they then set a huge fire and
killed them all that story was passed
down for hundreds of years and was
considered to be a fairy tale
but in 1911 the cave was discovered by
local miners and over the next 10 years
it was excavated and inside they found
skeletons over six feet six inches tall
who had red hair
[Music]
the legend of the moon eyed people is
still a mystery and a lot of it is
unsolved
but not all of it let's go back to
prince matic of wales we don't know for
sure that he existed but we do know that
his father king owen of gwened did exist
and we know that queen elizabeth the
first was a big supporter of the prince
matic of gwyneth story in the late 16th
century england spain and portugal were
striving for supremacy of the new world
dr john d was an advisor to queen
elizabeth and is famous for coining the
phrase the british empire he told the
queen that she should lay claim to north
america
all of it john d convinced the queen
that because her family the house of
tudor was related to the gwyneth royal
family of wales she could claim title to
the entire continent as it was her
ancestor prince matic of wales who got
there first i remember morgan jones the
welsh preacher whose life was spared by
the welsh indians well his story was
said to have happened in 1666 but the
story wasn't actually published until
the 1740s almost 100 years later when
england was at war with spain now morgan
jones story appeared in several london
journals and became a source of
fascination with the english and pride
amongst the welsh propaganda or was
published under the title the crown of
england's title to america prior to that
of spain not exactly unbiased no it
wasn't as for the stone ruins and mounds
found in cahokia and all around that
part of the country when european
settlers came across these structures
they just couldn't attribute them to
local native tribes who they considered
savages a city twice the size of london
was so shocking that they thought it
must have been created by a different
race white people right
now same with the welsh language myth
most of the american colonists were
simple and uneducated american indian
languages would have sounded like
nothing more than gibberish to them but
the same could be said for basque
finnish and even welsh these europeans
couldn't imagine that what they saw as
an inferior people could develop a
complex language so they attributed it
to european specifically welsh influence
in fact in 1791 john williams a welsh
minister wrote that words in common use
on different parts of the continent
which are very near or undeniably welsh
in both sound and sense could not happen
by chance and they could not be derived
from any europeans but from the ancient
britons and explorers quickly seized on
native words that were similar in welsh
like presso for welcome and bara for
bread but they ignored the many many
other words that aren't even close the
media has been spitting out fake news
and propaganda for a long time huh a
long time
there was a lot of excitement when
british explorers found a tribe in
virginia who had a word for penguin that
sounded a lot like penguin which in
welsh means whitehead however penguins
heads are black how did welsh indians in
virginia even know what a penguin was
that's a good point but when a probably
fake story like the one about the welsh
preacher goes viral people are going to
be able to find all sorts of data to
back up the theory especially if it
serves their agenda to me these are
pretty logical explanations for why for
centuries people believe there were
white welsh indians living in the
americas but the truth is there probably
weren't any what about the moonaid
people the statue discovered on cherokee
land what about the mounds and
metropolis at cahokia well nobody has
really explained these yet
that's why it's a great story
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything do me a favor and hit
all the buttons down there
i know it's
a small thing but it really helps out
the channel well until next time be safe
be kind now that you are appreciated
[Music]
so
you